Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I don't know who you are. I don't know what you want. If you're looking for a ransom, I can tell you I don't have money. But what I do have are a very particular set of skills. Skills I have acquired over a very long career. Skills that make me a nightmare for people like you.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我不知道你是谁。我不知道你想要什么。如果你在寻找赎金，我可以告诉你，我没有钱。但我确实拥有一套非常特殊的技能。这些技能是我在漫长的职业生涯中掌握的。这些技能让我成为像你这样的人的噩梦。
If you let my daughter go now, that will be the end of it. I will not look for you. I will not pursue you. But if you don't, I will look for you. I will find you. And I will kill you. Liam Neeson there. Dominic Sandberg. Who else? What accent was that?
如果你现在放了我女儿，这事就算了。我不会找你。我不会追究你。但如果你不放，我就会找你。我找到你。然后我会杀了你。那是连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）。多米尼克·桑德伯格（Dominic Sandberg）。还有谁？那是什麽口音？
That was like a man from Norfolk. It wasn't. No, it was an American Irish accent. That was absolutely shocking. With a deep, manly timbre. You did a fantastic New York Times. You did a twelfth Edward Heath. And then it's all gone wrong. No, it hasn't.
听起来像诺福克（Norfolk）人。才不是。不，那是美式爱尔兰口音。这绝对太糟糕了。带着深沉、男性的音质。你模仿的纽约时报太棒了。你还模仿了第十二任爱德华·希思（Edward Heath）。然后全盘皆输了。不，才没有。
That was absolutely superb. And the reason that I've chosen to open an episode that is on the CIA with that. Yes. Because in that Liam Neeson is playing Brian Mills, whose daughter gets abducted. And he brings the skill set of a CIA agent. But at no point in that film does he mention that he's in the CIA because he doesn't need to. All right. He doesn't need to because it can be automatically assumed that, you know, these are the skills that he has.
那真是绝了。我之所以选择用这个来开头一集关于中央情报局（CIA）的节目。没错。因为在那个片段里，连姆·尼森饰演的是布莱恩·米尔斯（Brian Mills），他的女儿被绑架了。他拿出了中情局特工的技能。但在这部电影的任何地方，他都没有提到自己在中情局，因为他不需要。好吧。他不需要，因为大家可以自然而然地认为，你知道，这些就是他具备的技能。
And it gives him the kind of the aura of combined competence and menace that the CIA at its best wants to convey and that people associate with the hosts of this podcast absolutely yes absolutely but as someone who doesn't know a huge amount about the CIA what I'd like to know is um are they as menacing and are they as competent as Liam Neeson might imply? Well, I thought that for this podcast, we needed somebody who was competent and menacing, but also had an interestingly transatlantic accent, a bit like the accent you were just doing. So when I first met him, he was a man very much of the West Country who taught alongside me at the University of Sheffield.
这赋予了他一种能力与威严并存的光环，这正是中情局在巅峰时期想要传达的，也是人们将它与本播客的主持人联系在一起的特质，绝对是的，绝对是的。但作为一个对中情局了解不算太多的人，我想知道的是，嗯，他们真的像连姆·尼森暗示的那样充满威严且能力出众吗？嗯，我认为对于这期播客，我们需要一个既有能力又具威严，同时还带着有趣的跨大西洋口音的人，有点像你刚刚模仿的那种口音。所以我第一次见到他时，他是一个非常典型的英格兰西南部（West Country）人，曾在谢菲尔德大学（University of Sheffield）和我一起教书。
But he's since moved to California, and listeners may be able to detect a little bit of kind of the Prince Harry in his voice, if not his demeanor and outlook, I hope. So this is Professor Hugh Wilford, who is one of the world's leading authorities. I would say the leading authority. The top authority. The top authority, the absolute supremer of CIA studies. So, Hugh, welcome to the podcast. Thank you for coming. Thank you for having me. It's a pleasure to be here.
但他后来搬到了加利福尼亚，听众们或许能从他的声音中听出一点哈里王子（Prince Harry）的感觉，虽然我希望他的风度和人生观不是这样。所以这位是休·威尔福德（Hugh Wilford）教授，他是世界领先的权威之一。我可以说他是绝对的权威。顶级权威。顶级权威，中情局研究领域的绝对泰斗。休，欢迎来到本播客。谢谢你能来。谢谢邀请我。很高兴能来到这里。
Excellent. So there you've got the accent straight away. Especially after that introduction. There you've got the accent. You've got the tone of menace and the competence. I'm known for my tone of menace. Oh, yes. People are going to mark on it. Prejudice. I'm known for my tone of menace. Oh, yes.
太棒了。所以你一上来就听出了那种口音。特别是经过那个介绍之后。口音这不就来了。那种威严的语气和能力。我一向以威严的语气闻名。哦，是的。人们会注意到的。偏见。我以威严的语气闻名。哦，是的。
So, Hugh, as I've said, I am incredibly ignorant about the CIA beyond, obviously, my amazing ability to do impersonations of Liam Neeson. And what I'm wondering is, the CIA, America doesn't have a kind of central intelligence agency before the war, does it? Before the Second World War. That's correct. It does not. And am I right that it's basically modeled on the British example? And the CIA agents, to begin with, all sit around smoking pipes and wearing tweed jackets and things. That's about right. Yeah, there's no sort of national intelligence service that throughout american history the the pattern has sort of been that uh intelligence services are sort of patched together uh during war and then dismantled uh rapidly afterwards because you know americans don't like secrecy they they don't
所以，休，正如我所说，我对中情局可以说是极度无知，除了我那模仿连姆·尼森的惊人天赋之外。我想知道的是，美国在战前并没有某种中央情报局，对吧？在第二次世界大战之前。没错。确实没有。我说的对吗，它基本上是以英国为模板建立的？而且中情局特工一开始都坐在那里抽烟斗、穿着花呢夹克之类的？差不多是这样。是的，没有那种全国性的情报机构，纵观美国历史，其模式基本上是，情报部门在战争期间拼凑起来，然后在战后迅速解散，因为你知道，美国人不20喜欢保密，他们不
like big government uh etc um but uh the the office of strategic services is created during world war ii and and it's it is right, sort of largely based on a British model. And the British actually are sort of on the sidelines, urging the Americans to go down the intelligence route, as they have several years before. And so there is this kind of, certainly in the early days, there is this kind of very strong anglophile, almost sort of faux imperial British tone to the CIA.
喜欢大政府，诸如此类。嗯，不过战略情报局（OSS）是在二战期间创建的，它确实很大程度上是基于英国的模式。而且英国人实际上在一旁敦促美国人走情报路线，就像他们几年前做的那样。因此，在这其中，当然特别是在早期，中情局有一种非常浓厚的亲英色彩，甚至带有一种伪帝国的英国基调。
So that's the pipe smoking. Because when you see, I agree with Tom, whenever you see pictures of early CIA men, they are wearing tweed jackets and sitting in kind of leather armchairs and smoking pipes and stuff, aren't they? Right. A little unexpectedly, possibly. I think you're probably thinking in particular of Alan Dulles, who was the great white case officer. As he was known, he was the sort of the first legendary director of the CIA during the 1950s and very much sort
所以这就是抽烟斗的由来。因为当你看到，我同意汤姆的看法，每当你看到早期中情局人员的照片时，他们都穿着花呢夹克，坐在某种皮质扶手椅里抽着烟斗之类的，对吧？没错。可能有点出乎意料。我想你可能特别想到了艾伦·杜勒斯（Alan Dulles），他当时是伟大的白人案件负责人。正如他所知，他是20世纪50年代中情局的第一任传奇局长，并且很大程度上
of sets the tone. He's Tweedy. He's sort of Ivy League. He's Kipfingsque as well. All of this generation of CIA officers have read Kip read things Kim and sort of rather, I think, see themselves in the same tradition. And this ability to engage in espionage and covert action sort of allows them to go and have adventures in foreign lands and generally sort of emulate the spies of British imperial romantic spy fiction. And is that kind of closeness? Kim Philby is the famous British traitor. He's the kind of liaison officer, isn't he,
定下了基调。他穿着花呢夹克。他有点常春藤盟校风格。也很吉卜林式。这一代的中情局官员都读过吉卜林的作品，比如《吉姆》（Kim），并且我认为，他们相当大程度上认为自己承袭了相同的传统。这种从事间谍活动和秘密行动的能力，让他们能够去异国他乡进行冒险，并大体上效仿英国帝国浪漫间谍小说中的间谍。这种紧密联系是怎样的？金·菲尔比（Kim Philby）是那个著名的英国叛徒。他可以说是英国秘密情报局和后来成型的中情局之间的联络官，对吧？他狠狠地把他们给坑了。他确实这么做了。完全正确。他在二战期间结交了许多美国人。像詹姆斯·安格尔顿（James Angleton）这样的人来到伦敦加入了他
between British Secret Service and the CIA as it comes to be. And he stitches them up royally. He does indeed. That's absolutely right. He befriends a number of Americans during World War II. People like James Angleton come and join him in London
来共同负责盟军的反间谍工作，并在20世纪40年代末他被派往华盛顿担任军情六处（MI6）和新成立的中情局之间的联络人时，他又恢复了与美国人的友谊。当然，在此期间，他被告知了各种中情局的
to sort of run Allied counterintelligence. And he resumes his friendships with the Americans in the late 1940s when he's sent over to Washington to act as the liaison between MI6 and the new CIA. And of course, during this, he is briefed on various CIA
秘密行动，尤其是包括将特工空投到铁幕背后像阿尔巴尼亚这样的国家的企图。而他显然把自己知道的一切都泄露给了他的苏联情报主子。有些美国人也曾起疑心，平心而论，特别是盖伊·伯吉斯（Guy Burgess）逃离华盛顿之后。他当时也在那儿。但美国人仍然与菲尔比保持着联系，安格尔顿在整个50年代末甚至几乎直到事实上，甚至直到菲尔比在1963年真正叛逃之前，都一直是他的朋友。我本来想说，回到最初的创立，也就是作为中情局前身的OSS，它基本上是美国第一个主要的特工组织，所以它最初主要是反纳粹的，
covert operations, including in particular attempts to land agents behind the Iron Curtain in countries like Albania. And he obviously passes on everything he knows to his Soviet controllers. And some Americans are suspicious to give them their due, especially after Guy Burgess flees Washington. He's there as well. But the Americans stay in touch with Philby and Angleton sort of remains a friend of his through the late 1950s and almost right up, in fact in touch with Philby and Angleton sort of remains a friend of his through the late 1950s and almost right up in fact up until Philby actually defects in 1963. I was going to say to go back to the foundation so the OSS which is the ancestor of the CIA which is basically the first sort of major American intelligence organization so that was anti-Nazi
我想是的，但随后中情局在47年由杜鲁门建立，那么他们是直接转换了目标，还是换了不同的人员，他们是如何从反纳粹调整为反共的，或者说OSS本来也是反共的？其实OSS相当自由派，就它拥有的任何政治倾向而言，而且这第一代中情局官员中有很多，除了那种吉卜林式的色彩之外，他们也都相当理想主义。尽管他们热爱英国的一切，但其中有相当多的人，他们其实并不是英国殖民主义的有意识的崇拜者。
I assume primarily but then the CIA is 47 set up by Truman so is that is do they simply switch targets or do they get different people in or how do they adjust from being anti-nazi to anti-communist or was the OSS anti-communist too? Now the OSS is actually quite liberal to sort of the extent it has in any politics at all and there's a lot of this first generation of CIA officers, sort of in addition to the kind of Kipfing element, they're all quite idealistic as well. Despite their love of things British, there's quite a lot of, they're not actually sort of conscious admirers of the British Empire.
如果要说的话，他们反而是有点反殖民主义的。OSS中甚至有一种几乎是左翼的色彩，以及他们试图与抵抗运动联合的举动，以至于OSS外部的一些人，比如保守派国会议员之流，非常不喜欢这个组织，将其视为“粉红分子”（同情共产主义者）和潜在共产主义者的温床。而这种印象实际上也一直困扰着早期的中情局。但回答你的问题，基本上是同一批人员在1947年中情局成立时转入了中情局，其中有相当一部分人。杜鲁门不喜欢间谍活动，不喜欢秘密行动，他很急切地想要解散OSS。
If anything, they're sort of anti-colonial. And there is this almost this, actually this leftist tinge to the OSS and their attempts to sort of join up with resistance movements to the extent that some people outside the OSS, sort of conservative congressmen and what have you, really dislike this organization and see it as a sort of nest of pinkos and possible communists. And this actually sort of haunts the early CIA as well. But in answer to your question, it is much the same personnel basically go to the CIA when it's created in 1947, a number of them. Truman doesn't like espionage, doesn't like covert operations, and he's quite eager to disband the OSS.
这是因为他认为这不美国吗？完全正确。是的。当时大约在1947年中情局创建时，有一种说法是担心建立一个美国的“盖世太保”会有危险。而且杜鲁门显然也有一些个人的顾虑。47年在椭圆形办公室里，他曾参与了一场针对首任中央情报局局长的某种“册封爵士”的恶搞仪式。他把这个职位交给了他的一个私人朋友，也就是他的一位密苏里老相识，并宣布他是“集中窥探局局长”。所以在当时周围有很多这样的传言。而杜鲁门实际上起到了遏制中情局扩张的刹车作用。直到艾森豪威尔
Is that because he sees them as un-American? Exactly. Yes. Yeah. And there's this sort of talk of the dangers of creating an American Gestapo around in 1947 when the CIA was created. And Truman obviously has sort of personal misgivings. He there's this point he participates in this kind of mock knighting ceremony of his first the first director of central intelligence in 47 in the Oval Office. He gives it to a personal friend, sort of an old Missouri acquaintance of his, and he declares him the director of centralized snooping. So there's a lot of talk like this around at the time. And Truman actually kind of acts as a sort of a brake on the expansion of the CIA. It's not really until Eisenhower
在1953年上台后，白宫才真正彻底放开了它。所以有一个显而易见的问题，马克·柯克·阿尔维斯（Mark Kirk Alviz）——我必须说他听起来本身就像个中情局特工——他问，马克问道：中情局在它成立之初是必要的吗？归根结底，美国是二战的超级大国胜利者，面临着潜在的苏联。难道除了建立一个间谍机构之外别无选择了吗？我认为这是注定会发生的。二战结束时，美国真的是最后一个屹立不倒的大国，而OSS解散后，它实际上没有任何情报能力。所以我认为这个机构的创建是不可避免的。
comes along in 1953 that the White House really lets it loose. So there's an obvious question, which Mark Kirk Alviz, who I have to say sounds like a CIA operative himself. And he asked, Mark asks, was the CIA necessary at its inception? So ultimately, America is the superpower victor in the Second World War, facing potentially the Soviet Union. Is there no choice but to set up a spy agency? I think it's bound to happen. The last great power standing really isn't at the end of World War II and lacks really any sort of intelligence capabilities after the OSS is disbanded. So I think it's inevitable this is going to be created.
最初，它在很大程度上被视为仅仅是一个情报机构，一个只负责收集情报、不一定参与秘密行动的组织。那是它的创建过程中的某种第二阶段。真具有讽刺意味的是，乔治·凯南（George Kennan），他或许最被人铭记的是美国遏制政策的架构师，他在构建这种相当微妙且理性的冷战外交政策，但实际上他在幕后也是政治战和心理战的大力倡导者，主张真正向苏联发起进攻，把斗争带到他们家门口。他推动了——虽然当时不一定是中情局——尽管如此，让政府拥有
And initially, it's very much seen just as an intelligence outfit, an organization that's going to gather intelligence, not necessarily engage in covert action. That's the sort of, there's a kind of second phase to its creation. Really, ironically, George Kennan, who's perhaps best remembered as the architect of containment in this rather subtle intellectual
一种秘密行动的能力，能够向阿尔巴尼亚空投特工，然后到了50年代，这开始进入去殖民化世界以及全球南方（Global South）的领域。但你的其中一个，我的意思是，你提到他们起初对秘密行动持怀疑态度，但他们不是立刻就干预了意大利大选吗？我是说，他们才成立一年，中情局成立于1947年，意大利大选是在1948年，他们给了基督教民主党大量的资金。哇，我想起来了，是的，他们确实这么做了，这千真万确。但某种程度上，这也是一次非常拼凑的行动。
creating Cold War foreign policy in the US, but he's actually behind the scenes. He's also a big advocate of political warfare and psychological warfare and really going after the Soviets and taking the fight to them. And he pushes for, it's not necessarily the CIA at this point, nonetheless, theviets and sort of taking the fight to them and he pushes for it's not necessarily the cia at this point nonetheless that government having it having
其中有私人公民的参与。最初，这类行动被交给了这个——其实不是中情局本身，而是交给了这个名为“政策协调办公室”（Office of Policy Coordination）的独立单位。它设在中情局内部，
a sort of a covert action capability so capable you know dropping uh agents into albania and then eventually come the 1950s you know this starts to go into areas of of the um the decolonizing world as as well the global south but one of your um i mean you said that they that first they're they're suspicious of covert action but don't they don't they influence the italian election straight away i mean they've only been going for a year uh so they're founded in 1947 the italian election is 48 and they give tons of money to the christian democrats wow i remembered yes they do that's true but it kind of partly, it's a very sort of patched together effort.
但实际上是由国务院和国防部运营的。直到，我想是52年或53年，它才被中情局吞并。所以这种对美国搞肮脏把戏的想法的抵抗——就像老牌帝国列强那样——是根深蒂固的，这意味着甚至连中情局本身其实也不一定想要这些东西，第二任中央情报局局长（在艾伦·杜勒斯之前），罗斯科·希伦科特（Roscoe Hillenkotter），一个很漂亮的美国名字。
There are sort of private citizens involved. Initially, these sorts of operations are given to this, not actually the CIA itself, they're given to this separate unit called the Office of Policy Coordination. It's housed by the CIA,
他叫什么名字？罗斯科·希伦科特。是的，他就像个军人，非常正直。他实际上抵制中情局承担这些权力。但多米尼克，是的，你是对的。当时确实有行动正在进行，首先是在欧洲，企图稳定欧洲局势并防止可能的共产主义接管。那是“政策协调办公室”，对吧？
but it's actually run by the State Department and the Defense Department. And it's not until, I think it's housed by the CIA but it's actually run by the State Department and the Defense Department and it's not until I think it's 52 or 53 that it's absorbed by the CIA so there's this kind of resistance to the idea of sort of the US doing dirty tricks you know like the old imperial powers that it's very much there and it means that not even the CIA itself actually necessarily wants these things that the second DCI before the Director of Central Intelligence, before Alan Dulles, Roscoe Hillenkotter, splendid the American name.
没错，是的。所以这是推翻外国政府的一种委婉说法，基本上就像詹姆斯·邦德的掩护身份是“环球出口公司”一样，对吧？是的，这显然是一个故意取得平淡无奇的名字，以转移人们的注意力。但这某种程度上反映了美国的理想主义，即美国不应该涉足这种肮脏的勾当，然而它的存在本质上反映了美国觉得自己不得不涉足这一事实。完全正确。是的，有像凯南这样的人说，你知道，我们需要清醒地认识到我们的责任和现代世界的危险。而且我认为他有意识地认为，既然我们如此天真，我们就需要效仿老牌欧洲列强。然后还有像艾伦·杜勒斯这样的人，我认为他们只是热爱某种间谍游戏。
What was he called? Roscoe Hillenkotter. Yes, he's like a military man and very upright. And he actually resists the CIA sort of adopting the powers. But Dominic, yes, you're right. There are operations going on, first of all, in Europe in this attempt to sort of stabilize it and prevent a possible communist takeover. It was the Office of Policy Coordination, was it?
而且他们真的，你知道，杜勒斯显然只是热爱二战以及协助运营OSS。他在比尔·多诺万（Bill Donovan，人称“野比尔”William Wild Bill Donovan）手下工作，多诺万是美国秘密行动的另一位创始人。我认为他只是想要更多这样的行动。所以他也在极力推动。我认为这幅画面的底色是，这些形形色色的知识分子和前秘密特工，几乎可以说是半推半就地促使华盛顿和杜鲁门等人走向了这条路。而参与中情局的人员，简单来说，
That's right, yeah. So this is a euphemism for kind of toppling foreign government, basically. Like universal exports, is James Bond's cover, isn't it? Yeah, it is clearly a deliberately sort of bland name to divert attention away. But it kind of reflects an American idealism, the notion that America shouldn't be in this dirty business, and yet its existence essentially reflects the fact that America feels that it has to be. That's just right. Yeah, there are these people like there's sort of people like Kennan saying, you know, we need to sort of wise up to our responsibilities and the sort of the dangers of the modern world. And he actually, I think, consciously thinks in terms of being so innocent, we need to sort of emulate the old European powers. And then there are sort of people like Alan Dulles, who I think just they love kind of spy games.
我的意思是，你刚才提到了常春藤盟校。所以萦绕在我脑海中的刻板印象是，这部分是因为那种穿着花呢夹克、抽着烟斗的风格，他们全都是常春藤盟校毕业的，你知道的，不像汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），他们会在游艇上穿对鞋子。我是说，我总是在游艇上穿对鞋子，这就是我一直提起它的原因。你才没有，你在考斯（Cowes）时出丑了，不是吗？就像那个——没有，我有，是的。嗯，那么休，他们确实非常符合美国东海岸社会上流社会的“蓝血”阶层，还是说情况要复杂得多？这创始的一代，你完全说对了，非常具有贵族气派，非常常春藤盟校。如果你看他们的名单，数量惊人的人都去过同一所预科学校——格罗顿公学（Groton）
And they really, you know, Dulles clearly had just loved World War II and helping run the OSS. He wasn't under Bill Donovan, William Wild Bill Donovan, who is the other sort of founding father of US covert operations. And he, I think, just wants more of that. So he's pushing for it as well. I think the sort of picture is of these various kind of intellectuals and former covert operatives sort of almost kind of pushing Washington and people like Truman almost unwillingly towards this. And the people who are involved in the CIA, just a quick, so,
位于新英格兰。就像罗斯福（FDR），罗斯福的母校。所以完全正确。是的，罗斯福家族在格罗顿随处可见。还有罗斯福家族的牡蛎湾（Oyster Bay）支系。西奥多（Teddy）和他的儿子孙子们也都去那里。西奥多本人没有去，但他那一脉罗斯福家族的后代去了。我曾看过去世纪30年代格罗顿的年鉴。简直就像是，“哦，对，我认识这个名字。我认识那个名字，”因为其中有太多人最终进了中情局。它非常像一所英国公学（私立寄宿学校）。并且它很大程度上
I mean, you mentioned Ivy League earlier. so the sort of stereotype floating around my mind is it's partly that sort of tweedy pipe smoking so they're all ivy league you know unlike tom holland they would wear the right shoes on a yacht are they i always wear the right shoes on a yacht that's why i keep bringing it up you don't you were shamed at cows weren't you like the no i was yes um yeah uh so so hugh they are they are very much kind of the blue bloods are they of kind of east coast american society or is it more complicated than that this founding generation are you absolutely right is is is very patrician it's very ivy league an extraordinary number if you look at the a number just went to this one prep school groton
灌输了经典的英国爱国主义、服务和责任等美德。而且这些家伙都在读吉卜林和T·E·劳伦斯（T.E. Lawrence）的书。那是冒险主义与责任感的某种结合。还有贵族式的某种心态，比如，“我们最懂。”我们有权从事这类活动，即使有些人反对。所以我觉得这些都融入了中情局。你提到了西奥多·罗斯福。那是他的孙子，对吧？
in in in in the sort of the new like side. Like FDR, FDR's old school. So that's absolutely right. Yeah, the Roosevelt's are everywhere in Groton. The Oyster Bay sort of line of the Roosevelt's as well. Teddy and his sons and grandsons all went there as well. Not Teddy himself, but later generations of that branch of the Roosevelt family. And I was looking at a yearbook from Groton in the 1930s. And it's almost like, oh, yeah, I know that name. I know that name, because so many of them end up in the CIA. It's very much, it's a kind of almost like a faux British public school. And it very much
科米特，名字起得极好的科米特·罗斯福（Kermit Roosevelt），所有《布偶秀》（Muppet Show）的粉丝听到都会感到一种小小的刺激。一点小小的刺激。他是中东的一个关键人物，是这样吗？特别是伊朗，在20世纪50年代初，伊朗成为了中情局介入英国情报部门曾玩过的那些肮脏把戏的橱窗。事实上，中情局可以说是介入并与英国情报部门联手，在伊朗策划了一场政变，这场政变至今仍影响着伊朗对美国的看法。所以你能给我们讲讲这方面的情况吗？
sort of inculcates, you know, classic sort of British virtues of patriotism and service and duty. And also these guys are all reading Kipthing and Amirah of T.E. Lawrence. It's that sort of combination of adventurism and a sort of sense of duty. And also aristocratic kind of like, you know, we know best. And we have the right to get up to these sorts of activities, even if some people object. So I think they will feed into the CIA. So you mentioned Theodore Roosevelt. And it's his grandson, isn't it?
是的，背景是这样的：一位资深的伊朗民族主义者穆罕默德·摩萨台（Mohammad Mosaddegh）成为首相，并将基本上由英国控制的伊朗石油产业收归国有，这让他们非常不高兴。英伊石油公司（Anglo-Iranian Oil Company）我想就是当年的石油巨头。那是英国石油（BP），没错，正是因为BP，完全正确。所以是英国人首先想除掉他。但他们意识到，部分原因是因为他们中的许多人被赶出了摩萨台的伊朗，他们需要让美国人参与进来，才能真正让政变尘埃落定。在这一点上，他们联系了科米特·罗斯福，
Kermit, the brilliantly named Kermit Roosevelt, which all fans of the Muffet show always gives a kind of thrill. A little thrill. He's a kind of key figure in the Middle East. Is that right? And specifically in Iran, which in the early 1950s, Iran becomes the kind of the showcase for the CIA's involvement in the kind of dirty tricks that British intelligence had played. And indeed, the CIA kind of enters, joins up with British intelligence, basically to foist a coup in Iran that still influences how Iran sees America to this day. So can you just tell us a bit about that?
作为一名美国贵族，他与许多英国贵族家庭之间存在着王朝般的联系。我忘了，我的意思是，事实上，他的一个家庭朋友是当时的英国外交大臣，我想。不管怎样，这一切都是在俱乐部的密谋中进行的，当时罗斯福正路过那里，是的，它最终导致了在1953年8月的这次合作，当时罗斯福组织了许多前英国特工、伊朗军队，还有一些穆斯林神职人员也参与其中。不管怎样，他们团结在沙阿（国王）身后，引发了一场宪政危机，迫使人们在沙阿和摩萨台之间做出选择，而这场政变实际上在某个时刻
Yeah, the background is this sort of veteran Iranian nationalist, Mohammad Mosaddegh, becomes prime minister and nationalizes the Iranian oil industry, which is basically controlled by the british so that they're they're not at all happy uh the anglo-iranian oil company i think is is the big you know the oil business of the day it's bp yes it's because of the bp exactly yeah uh and so it's it's the british who want rid of him initially and but they sort of realize, partly because a number of them are chased out of Mosaddegh's Iran, they need to involve the Americans in order to actually make a coup stick. And at this point, they reach out to Kermit Roosevelt,
几乎要分崩离析了。罗斯福当时甚至接到命令要撤出德黑兰，但具有早期中情局冒险主义风格的他却说：“不，我们还能行。”他收买了一些街头暴徒，8月19日，一群人占领了德黑兰街头，摩萨台基本上被赶跑了。而此前已经逃离德黑兰的沙阿——对不起——沙阿在这个时候回来了，这标志着他压迫性统治的开始，正如你所说，对它的抵抗也随之积聚。所以这是背景故事的一部分。我的意思是，关于1979年伊朗革命的起源究竟有多少可以直接追溯到1953年，一直存在争议。但显然这是一个重大因素。那么，这是否赋予了中情局——所以这是第一场由中情局支持的重大政变，对吧？
who actually, he has, you know, being a sort of an American aristocrat, there are sort of dynastic ties between him and various British aristocratic families as well. I forget the, I mean, he actually, a family friend is the then British Foreign Secretary, I think. Anyway, so it's all sort of, you know, this is being sort of hatched in in in clubs in as as roosevelt passes through and yes it eventually leads to um this this cooperation in august 1953 when um roosevelt uh organizes a lot of sort of former british agents and the iranian army and and some um muslim clerics are involved as well and and anyway they they sort of rally behind the shah and uh sort of force this kind of constitutional crisis in which people are forced to choose between the shah and and most today and uh it actually kind of falls apart
因为他们在第二年又在危地马拉搞了一次。然后任何研究60年代和70年代冷战史的人都会发现，基本上每年都会发生一场政变，人们会说，“哦，那是中情局干的，”或者“中情局的手脚不干净。”你认为伊朗行动的成功让中情局尝到了干涉的甜头，比如推翻政府之类的事情吗？还是说这有点被夸大了？不，我认为完全正确。这说服了德怀特，新总统德怀特·艾森豪威尔，认为秘密行动是冷战中的某种“银弹”（万灵药），你知道，你可以求助于中情局，因为它更便宜，动静也更小。因为你不想
at one point this coup plot uh roosevelt is actually sort of ordered to evacuate Tehran, but he, in sort of the adventurous style of the early CIA, says, no, we can still do this, and pays various street mob, a crowd takes over the streets of Tehran on August the 19th, and Mossadegh is basically chased out. And the Iran who's fled, excuse me, the Shah, who has fled Tehran at this point, comes back and it's the sort of beginning of his sort of repressive rule, which, as you say, resistance to it builds. And so this is sort of part of the back story. I mean, there are controversies about exactly how much of the origins of the 1979 Iranian revolution can be traced directly back to 1953. But clearly it is a big factor. And so does this give the CIA – so this is the first sort of great CIA-backed coup, isn't it?
出于显而易见的原因与苏联公开开战。你知道，那可能导致核战争。而且，我认为其中很大一部分原因也是，许多这样的干涉之所以是秘密的，是因为如果放在早期，它们可能是公开的。但是，你知道，这是去殖民化的时代。联合国宪章现在存在了，你知道，在国际社会看来，公开的干涉主义已不再被允许。所以这就是为什么华盛顿在冷战中经常伸手去拿这件武器。这些是1953年伊朗和1954年危地马拉的成功。
Because they have one in Guatemala the following year. And then sort of anyone who studies the history of the Cold War in the 60s and 70s, I mean, basically there's a coup every year that people say, oh, that's the CIA who did it, or the CIA's sort of hands are dirty. Do you think that the success of the operation in Iran gave the CIA a taste for meddling, as it were, for toppling governments and stuff? Or was that being overstated a bit? No, I think that's absolutely right. And it persuades Dwight, the new president, Dwight Eisenhower, that COVID action is this sort of magic bullet in the Cold War, you know, you can resort to the CIA, and it's cheaper, and it's less noisy. Because you don't, you don't want to
它们只是助长了一种日益增长的神话，即中情局有能力基本上做到任何事情，比如暗中推翻一些政权并支持其他政权。与此同时，越南也正在发生这种情况，中情局试图建立——我知道你曾在早期的播客中与安德鲁·普雷斯顿（Andrew Preston）讨论过越南战争的起源——早期中情局将吴庭艳（Diem）扶上台的尝试，在很大程度上也是一次中情局行动。我的意思是，这在当时的冷战中确实可以说是美国的军队。所以，是的。那么，来自“文化胡萝卜”（culture carrot）的一个问题：中情局曾密谋推翻多少外国领导人？其中对权力滥用最严重的例子是哪个？为什么？这某种程度上印证了你刚才所说的，
get into an overt fight with the Soviets for obvious reasons. You know, it could lead to nuclear war. And also, I mean, I think a big part of this as well is that so many of these interventions are covert because with an earlier generation that they might have been over. But, you know, this is this is the sort of the era of decolonization. UN Charter exists now, you know, overt interventionism is sort of no longer allowed in the eyes of the sort of international community. So this is kind of why Washington is often reaches for this weapon in the Cold War. And these are the successes in Iran, 1953, and Guatemala, 1954.
中情局确实推翻了外国政府。那么，这与另一个问题相关，即中情局是否享有与其地位不符的恶名？换句话说，它推翻政府的名声是否意味着，它被归咎于那些它实际上并未扮演任何角色的政变、内乱和外国崩溃？你认为这里的平衡点在哪里？当然。哇。确实有这方面的因素。我的意思是，有些人甚至认为，它在1953年伊朗政变中的角色都被夸大了。事实上，是当地的伊朗行动者发挥了决定性作用。我认为中情局本身也陷入了一种矛盾之中：一方面他们渴望吹嘘这些成功；另一方面，当长期结果证明这或许并不是个好主意时，他们又试图与之保持距离。所以你在关于伊朗的书面记录中看到了这种紧张关系。但我猜，伊朗是中情局实施政变的一个引人注目的例子，危地马拉也是。许多这样的企图，事实上其中绝大多数，我认为至少在50年代末和60年代初，后来都失败了。艾森豪威尔不断地使用这件武器，而它却一次次失效。叙利亚和印度尼西亚都遭遇了失败。当然，最严重的是古巴。这或许是中情局为推翻外国政权所做出的最糟糕的努力，那就是不断试图消灭菲德尔·卡斯特罗（Fidel Castro）。所以所有的滑稽事，你知道，比如试图让他的胡子脱落，还有什么，在……的贝壳里放炸药
They just kind of fuel this growing myth of the ability of the CIA to basically do whatever, you know, overthrow some regimes and support others secretly. So at the same time, this is going on in Vietnam, that the CIA is trying to sort of build up, I know you talked about the origins of the Vietnam War in an earlier earlier podcast with andrew preston you know early on the sort of the ci attempt to cement zm into place is very much a ci operation as well i mean it is the you know it is kind of america's army in the cold war at this point really so yeah so we've got a question from culture carrot um how many foreign leaders did the cia conspire to bring down and which is the most egregious example of misuse of power and why so that's that's kind of backing up what you're saying
他们去了他最喜欢的潜水海滩，试图把炸药放进他可能会拿到的贝壳里。是的，是的，这都是真的，千真万确。这一切都在20世纪70年代中期国会对中情局的调查中曝光了，并且这一切都有据可查。他们称之为“猫鼬行动”（Operation Mongoose），对吧？没错，是的。爆炸雪茄，爆炸雪茄是其中一部分，我想。好吧，当时有这样的企图，对吧，把东西抹在他的鞋子上，让他的胡子脱落。没错。是的。爆炸雪茄。爆炸雪茄是其中一部分，我想。好吧，当时有这样的企图，对吧，把东西抹在他的鞋子上，让他的胡子脱落。然后我——但我认为是神经毒素。没错，有些是滑稽可笑的。有些则，你知道，其实更加险恶。
that the cia did bring down foreign governments so so well essentially yes but but that's just i mean that question is in association with another question which is does the cia enjoy a notoriety beyond its station in other words does its reputation for bringing down governments mean that it gets, it's been blamed for coups and for kind of civil unrest and collapse in foreign countries where it hasn't actually played a role? And what's the balance there, do you think? Sure. Wow. There is an element to that. I mean, there are some people who actually think that even its role in the 1953 Iran coup has been overstated. And actually, you know, there was the local Iranian actors who read it, you know, they did the decisive things, which is kind of, I think the CIA itself is sort of caught between this desire to sort of boast of such successes. And then when it turns out in
我想是把毒药放进了他的雪茄里。然后还有一次企图，他们试图拉拢黑手党。你知道，中情局，为了拉拢黑手党，你知道，谁真正知道怎么干掉别人呢？是的，我们会——联邦调查局（FBI）让中情局联系了萨姆·吉安卡纳（Sam Giancana）的一个亲信，然后此人试图让哈瓦那黑手党去对付卡斯特罗。所以我的意思是，这绝对是疯狂的事情，但这是声誉与现实之间一种奇怪的张力——一方面中情局在60年代被视为一个阴险的幽灵般组织，能够拨弄几根弦就颠覆一个外国
the long term, perhaps this wasn't such a great idea after all, to sort of, you know, distance itself. So that's that tension you see sort of replicated in the writing about Iran. But I guess that, I mean, Iran is a conspicuous example of regime change by the CIA, Guatemala. A lot of these attempts, in fact, the majority of them, I think, at least in the late 50s and early 60s, are then unsuccessful. Eisenhower keeps reaching for this weapon, and it keeps not working. There are failures in Syria and Indonesia. And then, of course, most of all in Cuba. That's probably the most egregious CIA effort to overthrow a foreign regime is this constant effort to do away with Fidel Castro. So all the comedy, you know, the things about
政府；另一方面，又有着用爆炸雪茄之类东西暗杀的滑稽尝试。你认为哪一个对中情局造成的损害更大？一方面是无所不知、阴险狡诈的潜能的名声，还是无能的名声？我猜是无能，真的。是的，我认为最初很可能是无能开始让美国人对它感到反感。你知道，当古巴事件发生时，首先是1961年猪湾入侵的失败，接着是通过“猫鼬行动”暗杀卡斯特罗的后续企图的细节浮出水面。我认为正是在那时，美国公众开始——其中一些细节开始被媒体曝光，美国人开始对它反感。但我的意思是，始终存在这种对美国盖世太保的恐惧，以及美国反帝国主义这一可以追溯到几个世纪前的更悠久传统的可能性，即海外冒险和为了实施这些冒险而加强联邦政府，最终可能会反噬美国人。
them trying to get his beard to fall out and what is it, kind of exploding seashells on the... They went to his favourite diving beach and tried to put explosives in a shell that he might reach for and yeah yeah it's all it's all true it's all true yeah yeah yeah this all came out in uh in the mid 70s during congressional investigations of of the cia and uh this is all it's all documented they called it operation mongoose didn't they that's right yeah exploding cigar exploding cigar was part of it i think well there was this attempt right to put stuff on his shoes that would cause his his beard That's right. Yeah. Exploding cigar. Exploding cigar was part of it, I think. Well, there is this attempt, right, to put stuff on his shoes that would cause his beard to fall out. And then I but I think it was neurotoxins that that's right. It was some of it's comical. Some of it's, you know, is actually more sinister.
所以这种情绪大概在60年代和70年代随着反文化运动以及反对越战的抗议等达到了高潮。他们搞了一个行动，对吧，叫做“混乱行动”（Operation Chaos），用来调查谁——谁想出了“混乱行动”这个名字？这是一个很棒的名字。如果我要坦白的话，好吧，你刚才说你有自己的黑手党，科米特·罗斯福花钱雇了自己的暴徒，我的意思是，我也很想有自己的暴徒，但是，如果我要进行秘密行动，我会把它们命名为像“混乱行动”这样的名字。但“混乱行动”是为了渗透和平运动，“妇女争取和平”组织，还有黑人权力运动、黑豹党之类的，对吧，休？好吧，这里有一个来自纳瓦尔博士（Dr. Navar）的问题：中情局与其他联邦机构（如联邦调查局）之间的关系是怎样的？
I think it was poisons were going in his cigars. So and then there's an attempt that there's an attempt to involve the mafia. You know, the CIA, you to involve the mafia you know the the cia you know thinks you know who actually really knows to take out people yes we'll and the fbi puts the cia in touch with uh um friend of an associate of sam ginkanas who then who then tries to get the the havana mob to go after castro so i mean it's i mean it's it's crazy it's crazy stuff for sure but it's it's a weird a kind of weird tension between the reputation the cia said in the 60s has as this sinister kind of specter type organization that can pull a string and topple a foreign
联邦调查局管国内，中情局管国外，还是说我把问题简化得太过了？不，完全正确。那为什么中情局要干涉国内事务？我的意思是，他们是怎么逃脱惩罚的？好吧，部分原因是林登·约翰逊（Lyndon Johnson）发起了“混乱行动”。顺便说一句，这个名字据说来自一个可能的行动代号列表：灾难行动（Operation Catastrophe）、灾祸行动（Operation Disaster）、搞砸行动（Operation Screw Up）。
government and at the same time these kind of clownish attempts to you know with exploding cigars and things uh which do you think did the cia more damage time, these kind of clownish attempts to, you know, with exploding cigars and things. Which do you think did the CIA more damage? A reputation for kind of omniscient, sinister potency or incompetence? I guess incompetence, really. Yeah, I think probably initially it's the incompetence that starts to sour people on it in the United States. You know, when it's really Cuba and first of all, the failed invasion of the Bay of Pigs in 1961, and then the details which emerge of subsequent attempts via Operation Mongoose to assassinate Castro. I think that's when the American public sort of starts to and some of this starts to come out into the media and Americans start to sort of turn against it. But I mean, there is always this, you know, fear of an American Gestapo and the possibility to this kind of longer tradition of American anti-imperialism, you know, sort of going back centuries, really, and the thought that, you know, overseas adventures and strengthening federal government in order to carry these out might ultimately sort of boomerang against Americans.
你其实没法选，对吧？是的。它有一个数据库，里面记录了比如和平活动人士之类的详细信息。那个数据库被称为“九头蛇”（Hydra）。（心想：）我们还能想出更阴险的名字吗？但是，我也应该说句公道话，为了公平起见，中情局的很多行动其实都来自白宫。你知道，
So presumably that intensifies in the 60s and into the 70s with the counterculture and the protests against the vietnam war and so on they have a thing don't they called operation chaos to in who calls who calls the cia do yeah operation chaos who came up with that name it's a great name i mean if i was going to frankly i well you were talking about having your own mob kermit roosevelt paid his own mobs i mean i'd love to have my own mob but um if i was going to run covert operations i would call them things like operation chaos but operation chaos was about infiltrating the peace movement and sort of women for peace and yes the black power movement black panthers and stuff wasn't it huge well it's a question here from dr navar what is the relationship between the cia and other federal agencies such as the FBI?
历届美国总统都有这样一种倾向，把中情局视为某种私家军队，他们可以将其用于自己需要的任何目的。在特定情况下，是的，尼克松（Nixon）——节目老朋友尼克松，是的，尼克松讨厌中情局。你知道，多米尼克肯定能聊这个，他认为他们是一群常春藤盟校的书呆子，还有暗地里的左翼分子，我想这就是他的看法。他们确实在去海滩时穿对鞋子。所以他实际上，显然，总统简报和中情局的报告只是堆在他的保险箱里，你知道的，他根本懒得去读。但当他想要
The FBI is domestic and the CIA is foreign, or am I being too reductive there? No, that's absolutely right. So why is the CIA intervening in domestic? I mean, how do they get away with that? Well, it's partly because Lyndon Johnson, Operation Chaos. And by the way, that name, it came just supposedly from a list of, you know, possible operational code names. Operation Catastrophe. Operation Disaster. Operation Screw Up.
除掉智利的萨尔瓦多·阿连德（Salvador Allende）时，你知道，他想到了他们，因为他们很有用。所以阿连德，那是中情局干的吗？是的，是的。在1973年政变前的几年里，中情局开展了许多反阿连德的行动，但实际上在中情局的政变行动中，大多数历史学家现在倾向于
You can't really pick it up, can you? No. It had a database of sort of details of like peace activists and what have you. And that was called Hydra. You know, can we think of any more sinister names? But, and I should also, you know, in defense, in defense, the CIA, an awful lot of this is, is, is coming from the white house. You know,
认为，阿连德的实际倒台，其实并非像其他案例中那样是由中情局造成的。我的意思是，他们当时并不认为皮诺切特（Pinochet）会——你知道，根据中情局官员的说法，他当时甚至不在他们的视线之内。但这难道不是说明了一个更大的问题吗，休？那就是在很多事情上——你在1953年的伊朗问题上也提到过这一点——我们倾向于，尤其是那些人，嗯，美国的反建制派以及基本上美国以外的所有人都倾向于像汤姆那样做。像你这样的左翼分子，多米尼克。没错。危险的马克思主义者。是的。
there is this tendency on the part of successive us presidents to sort of see the, the, the, the CIOs, this kind of private army, they, they can use for any purpose really that that they need and in this particular instance is that yeah that that that's very much no nicks yes nixon friend of the show yeah nixon hates the cia you know dominic i'm sure could speak to this he sees he thinks they're a bunch of sort of ivy league eggheads yeah and closet left is i think is what he thinks they do wear the right shoes to the beach so he he actually he just apparently you know presidential briefs and the ci just sort of piled up in his safe you know it was just he never bothered to read them but when he wanted
喜欢把中情局想象成一个幽灵般的组织。你知道，这是个典型的阴谋论。所以中美洲共和国发生了什么事，那一定就是中情局的错。中情局往往也卷入了其中，但他们并不是关键角色。所以他们最终获得了功劳或承担了指责。但事实上，你提到了阿连德。我的意思是，我会说阿连德无论如何可能都会倒台。
to get rid of salvador allende in chile you know he kind of he calls on them because they're useful. So Allende, that is the CIA? Yes, yeah. There are a lot of anti-Allende operations run by the CIA during the years running up to the coup of 1973, but actually amongst CIA coup operations I think most historians now tend to
为了在智利摆脱萨尔瓦多·阿连德，你知道，他有点像是在利用他们，因为他们有用。所以阿连德，是指CIA？是的，没错。在1973年政变前的几年里，CIA进行了大量反阿连德的行动，但实际上在CIA的政变行动中，我想大多数历史学家现在倾向于
see that as actually having the actual overthrow of Allende itself as actually having been less caused of the end itself as actually having been less caused by the CIA than in other cases it was I mean they didn't think um Pinochet was going to you know he was barely even on their radar apparently the CIA officers but doesn't that speak to a bigger issue Hugh which is that in a lot of you you mentioned this with 1953 in Iran, that basically we tend, particularly people, well, sort of anti-establishment people in America and basically everybody outside America, we tend to do what Thomas does. Left-wingers like you, Dominic. Exactly. Dangerous Marxists. Yeah.
认为阿连德的实际被推翻，其实比其他情况下更少是由CIA引起的——我的意思是，他们当时并不认为……皮诺切特会……你知道的，显然在CIA官员的雷达里几乎都没有注意到他——但这难道不说明了一个更严重的问题吗，休？那就是在很多情况下，你刚才在讲1953年的伊朗时也提到了这一点，基本上我们倾向于——尤其是人们，嗯，美国的反体制人士以及基本上美国以外的所有人都倾向于像托马斯那样做。像你这样的左翼分子，多米尼克。没错。危险的马克思主义者。是的。
Like to think of the CIA as a spectre-type organisation. You know, it's a classic conspiracy theory. So something happens in a Central American republic, and it must be the CIA's fault. And often the CIA are involved, but they're not the key actors. So they end up getting the credit or the blame. But actually, you mentioned Allende. I mean, I would say Allende would probably have fallen anyway,
喜欢把中情局想象成一个幽灵般的组织。你知道，这是一个典型的阴谋论。因此，中美洲共和国发生了一定会是中情局的错。中情局通常会参与其中，但他们并不是关键角色。所以他们最终得到了赞誉或指责。但实际上，你提到了阿连德。我的意思是，我会说阿连德无论如何都可能会倒台，
whether the CIA had stayed at home playing backgammon or whether they'd actually got involved. You know, that's sort of letting his Chilean opponents off the hook in a weird way. Is that fair? There is. Yeah. And there's been some really great scholarship recently about the role of other South American dictatorships in Allende's overthrow. You know, Brazil played a uh in in this as well but then and and then as i was saying earlier that this has even gone into the iran coup and there have been these kind of retrospective attempts to almost excuse the us and the cia and actually you know but blame it all on the ayatollahs right this this is actually um so so in other words the
不管中央情报局是留在家里玩双陆棋，还是真的介入其中。你知道，从某种奇怪的角度来看，这有点放过了他的智利政敌。这样公平吗？确实如此。最近有一些非常棒的学术研究，探讨了其他南美独裁政权在阿连德被推翻过程中所扮演的角色。你知道，巴西在其中也扮演了……但随后，正如我刚才所说，这甚至延续到了伊朗政变，并且出现了一些事后的尝试，几乎是在为美国和中央情报局开脱，而实际上，你知道的，却把一切都归咎于阿亚图拉，对吧？实际上，这……所以换句话说，
sort of stressing local agency and saying no this wasn this wasn't just the case of the CIA turning up with some bags of gold and then sort of turning this sort of third world backwater into – and everything happening at the – And did they carry on with exploding cigars and things? Was that the kind of cool gadgets that – Did they carry on with – Well, it's what people really want to know i think i mean do they do they have because the whole exploding cigars did they just think this is a terrible idea we're going to park it or did they did their top boffins crack how to get
某种程度上强调了当地的主体性，并表示不，这不仅仅是中央情报局带着几袋黄金出现，然后把这个所谓的第三世界落后地区变成——而且一切都在——他们还继续搞爆炸雪茄之类的东西吗？这难道就是那种酷炫的小玩意吗？他们还在继续——好吧，这才是人们真正想知道的，我想我是说，他们有没有——因为整件事，关于爆炸雪茄，他们只是觉得这是个糟糕的主意，我们把它搁置一边，还是说他们的顶尖专家真的研究出了如何制作
exploding cigars because if they did presumably we wouldn't know would we so we'd only hear about the failures well some of this actually some of the gadgets actually and and are coming from well and again dominic will like this they're coming from bond um there's this for yeah um um fleming uh is a sort of dinner parties with with uh dulles and and and, and he is describing MI6 gadgets and then some of the things that feature in his novels. And apparently Alan Dulles runs off excitedly to see if the CIA boffins can replicate this
爆炸雪茄？因为如果他们真的研究出来了，想必我们也不会知道，对吧？所以我们只会听到失败的案例。好吧，事实上，其中一些小玩意确实来自于……而且，多米尼克会喜欢这个的，它们来自于詹姆斯·邦德……有一个关于，是的，弗莱明和杜勒斯一起参加晚宴，他描述了军情六处的各种小玩意，然后其中一些东西就出现在了他的小说里。显然，艾伦·杜勒斯兴奋地跑去看看中央情报局的专家们能不能在
in their laboratories. So apparently, including Rosa Klebb's poison knife. That comes out of a shoe. Yeah, that's right. Yeah, yes. Apparently, Dulles was very interested in this gadget. That's absolutely laughable. They were copying the thing.
实验室里复制出来。所以显然，包括罗莎·克莱布（Rosa Klebb）的毒鞋。那玩意是从鞋子里弹出来的。对，没错。对，是的。据说杜勒斯对这个小玩意非常感兴趣。这简直荒谬透顶。他们竟然在抄袭这种东西。
But I should also say, the CIA is actually quite, out of the various forms of intelligence, there are these abbreviations for human intelligence and technological intelligence. The CIA is actually, I mean, overall, it's probably not terribly good at human intelligence. It's, you know, notoriously, it fails to really kind of, you know, get much good intelligence, human intelligence from the Soviet Union. And then later from that, you know, the next big enemy from Al-Qaeda and other is the missed organizations. But what it is pretty good at is things like the U2 is a CI operation.
但我也得说，中央情报局其实相当……在各种情报形式中，有人力情报和技术情报的缩写。中央情报局其实，总的来说，在人力情报方面可能并不是特别擅长。你知道，众所周知，它并没有真正成功地……你知道，从苏联那里获得太多优质的人力情报。后来又从……你知道的，下一个大敌人基地组织以及其他伊斯兰极端组织那里获取情报。但它相当擅长的是，比如U2侦察机就是一个中情局行动。
You know, it's the CI that comes up. Because of the spy plane. This extremely effective spy plane. Not the band. Not the band. There are CIA links to the police. Of course, his dad, Miles Copeland's dad.
你知道，这就是中情局想出来的。因为那个间谍飞机。这个极其高效的间谍飞机。不是那个乐队。不是那个乐队。中央情报局与警察有联系。当然，他爸爸，迈尔斯·科普兰的爸爸。
Yes, exactly. So what was Miles Copeland's dad? Was he a major figure in the CIA? Yeah, he was quite big in the Middle East. He was a Kermit Roosevelt's kind of lieutenant, as it were. He's not very heavily involved in Iran, but he's very sort of active in the Middle East. He was a Kermit Roosevelt's kind of lieutenant, as it were. He's not very
对，没错。那么迈尔斯·科普兰的爸爸是谁？他是中情局的重要人物吗？对，他在中东相当有影响力。他可以说是克米特·罗斯福的副手。他在伊朗并没有深入参与，但在中东非常活跃。他可以说是克米特·罗斯福的副手。他并不是非常
heavily involved in Iran, but he's very sort of active in the Arab countries. And he's very good at cultivating human intelligence sources. He befriends NASA, for example. That's amazing. What a link to the police. I think we should take a break at this point. We should do. And I think when we come back, we should look at those two failures that you mentioned. Because the CIA didn't really predict the fall of the Soviet Union. And it didn't really get a handle on the rise of Al-Qaeda and Islamist militism. So when we come back, we talk about that.
深入地参与伊朗事务，但在阿拉伯国家非常活跃。他非常擅长培植人力情报来源。比如，他与纳赛尔交朋友。太惊人了。这跟警察有什么联系？我想我们现在应该休息一下了。我们确实该休息了。我想等我们回来后，我们应该看看你提到的那两个失败案例。因为中情局并没有真正预测到苏联的解体。它也没有真正掌控基地组织和伊斯兰激进主义的崛起。所以等我们回来后，我们来谈谈这个。
We will see you in a minute or two. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. in a minute or two. to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking the Central Intelligence Agency. And Hugh, I've got a question here from Alan Andrew Wild. In pursuing American interests, has the CIA ever been a source for good? And I guess you'd say that for all its fondness for coups and its exploding cigars and so on, you'd back the CIA over, say, the KGB and you'd back them over al-Qaeda. And in the 80s and the 90s, those were the two great enemies of the CIA, I guess. So how CIA, despite the sort of comical elements,
我们一两分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩余皆娱乐》。一两分钟后见。获取现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。我们正在讨论中央情报局。休，我这里有一个来自艾伦·安德鲁·怀德的问题。在追求美国利益的过程中，中央情报局曾经是一股向善的力量吗？我想你会说，尽管它对政变和爆炸雪茄等情有独钟，但比起克格勃，你还是会支持中情局，比起基地组织，你也会支持它。在80年代和90年代，我想这是中情局的两个最大敌人。那么中情局是如何在……尽管有一些滑稽的元素，
its operations are effective in the 80s, especially in defeating, helping defeat the Soviets in Afghanistan. The CIA supplies the Mujahideen with weapons, the Stinger missiles they fired at the Soviet helicopters. Is Rambo in the CIA? I don't think he is, no. There's no CIA presence, I have to say, in the living daylights. So that's just Bond. There's no CIA man there.
但它的行动在80年代是有效的，特别是在击败、协助击败阿富汗的苏联人方面。中情局向圣战者提供了武器，也就是他们向苏联直升机发射的毒刺导弹。兰博是中情局的人吗？我想他不是，没有。我必须说，《黎明生机》里没有中情局的存在。所以那只是邦德。里面没有中情局的人。
Right. So the CIA is in other Bond, isn isn't it felix lighter he's uh yes but felix is never instrumental guys felix is only ever supplying gadgets and stuff he's a sort of sidekick isn't he yeah we're not focusing on fantasy here we're focusing on on okay so reality of the cia's engagement in these titanic global you mentioned rambo you meant there's no time i know i did i know i did but i can just throw that out because i i know that we're not going to discuss it but we get into bond it's like kind of going down into quicksand with you okay all right all right sorry let's let's not talk about fictional agents let's talk about um so say in homeland well no i mean the relationship between the cia and and culture is very interesting
对。所以中情局在别的邦德电影里，对吧？是不是菲利克斯·莱特？他是……是的，但菲利克斯从来都不是关键人物，伙计。菲利克斯从来都只是提供一些小玩意之类的东西，他只是个某种程度上的跟班，对吧？是的，我们这里不关注虚构，我们关注的是……好吧，关于中情局卷入这些震撼全球的事件的现实……你提到了兰博，你意思是……我知道我提了，我知道我提了，但我只是顺便抛出来的，因为我知道我们不会讨论它，但是一旦扯到邦德，就感觉像是跟你一起陷入了流沙之中。好吧，好吧，好吧，抱歉，我们不要谈论虚构的特工了，我们来谈谈……比如说在《国土安全》中……不，我是说，中情局与文化的关系非常有趣，
you know i i think it's talking a bit earlier about kit thing and and alan dulles you know i i Well, I mean, the relationship between the CIA and culture is very interesting. You know, I think just talking a bit earlier about Kip thing and Alan Dulles, you know, I think fiction really does sort of shape the even the CIA's attitude towards a number of things. And there's this kind of there's the gadget thing, you know, coming out of Fleming. And then it's going the other way as well. You know, the CIA, it does somewhat try to shape to shape culture and then you've written a book about this you've written a whole book about this so i've been trying to turn the conversation around to his own book tom holland is a master of that so you wrote a book called the he wrote a brilliant book called the mighty which is all about the cia sponsoring what jackson pollock? Jackson Pollock? Literary magazines. Yeah, he's promoted by the CIA.
你知道，我……我想刚才稍微聊了一下吉普·辛格和艾伦·杜勒斯，你知道，我……好吧，我是说，中情局与文化的关系非常有趣。你知道，我想刚才稍微聊了一下吉普·辛格和艾伦·杜勒斯，你知道，我认为虚构作品确实塑造了甚至是中情局对许多事情的态度。这里面有这种小玩意儿的元素，你知道，源自弗莱明。然后它也朝着相反的方向发展。你知道，中情局确实在某种程度上试图塑造……去塑造文化，然后你写过一本书关于这个，你写了一整本书关于这个，所以我一直在试图把话题转到他自己的书上，汤姆·霍兰就是这方面的高手。所以你写过一本书叫……他写了一本精彩的书叫《强大的人》，全讲的是中情局资助什么？杰克逊·波洛克？杰克逊·波洛克？文学杂志。对，他是由中情局推崇的。
Why are they sponsoring Jackson Pollock? Hugh, you tell the story better than me. He's just kind of flicking paint, isn't he? Well, we'll see if I do. So, yeah, this is the so-called cultural Cold War. It's the idea that the US is sort of trying to fight this international image of itself as it's all Disney and Coca-Cola. So in order to sort of you know win over neutralist intellectuals in europe and then possibly a bit beyond in the third the so-called
他们为什么要资助杰克逊·波洛克？休，你来讲这个故事，讲得比我好。他其实就是在甩颜料，对吧？好吧，看看我是不是讲得更好。所以，是的，这就是所谓的文化冷战。其核心理念是，美国试图对抗其国际形象——那种全是迪士尼和可口可乐的形象。因此，为了赢得欧洲中立主义知识分子的支持，并在某种程度上可能扩大到第三世界——也就是所谓的
third world you need to persuade them that actually america has has a high cultural life of its own and you know the soviets are sort of soviet propagandists are making uh hay out of this as well you know we have the bolshoi we we have Tolstoy, what do the Americans have? So the CIA secretly funds this organization called the Congress for Cultural Freedom, which sponsors tours of Europe and further afield by the Boston Symphony Orchestra, for example, you know, to show what accomplished
第三世界，你需要说服他们，其实美国自身也有着崇高的文化生活，你知道，苏联人……苏联的宣传人员也在借此大作文章，你知道的，我们有大剧院，我们有托尔斯泰，美国有什么呢？于是中情局暗中资助了一个名为“文化自由大会”的组织，该组织赞助了波士顿交响乐团等机构在欧洲及更远地区的巡演，以展示美国拥有多么成熟的
classical musicians the US has. And traveling exhibits featuring the abstract expressionists. This is sort of in partnership with the Museum of Modern Art in New York and amongst them, Jackson Pollock. So this is really, I mean, perhaps this could be part of a response to that earlier question about the CIA really being pretty clever, right? You know, being pretty subtle.
古典音乐家。还有展出抽象表现主义作品的巡回展览。这其实是与纽约现代艺术博物馆合作进行的，其中包括杰克逊·波洛克。所以这真的，我的意思是，也许这可以作为对之前那个问题的部分回答，即中情局其实相当聪明，对吧？你知道，相当巧妙。
Am I imagining that they sponsored Orwell? Have I not got that right? Well, Orwell has a relationship with a sort of equivalent secret British organization, the Information Research Department in the British Foreign Office. No, but actually there is an Orwell CIA link as well because the CIA animates Animal Farm. That's right. Yeah, I mean,
我是不是记错了，他们还资助过奥威尔？我没记错吧？嗯，奥威尔与英国外交部下属的一个类似秘密机构——信息研究部——有着某种联系。不过事实上，确实也存在奥威尔与中情局的联系，因为中情局把《动物庄园》动画化了。没错。是的，我是说，
actually, you know, it's a great movie. It's sort of a landmark in the history of animation. And it's a CIA operation from beginning to end you know they think that the animal farm could be this sort of tremendous anti-communist propaganda and um they they rent this this production company based in in the uk in order to to to animate it and it's in the movie theaters it's in the uh it's shown in in classrooms for for
事实上，你知道，这是一部伟大的电影。它是动画史上的一个里程碑。从头到尾这都是一个中情局的行动，你知道，他们认为《动物庄园》可以成为一部巨大的反共宣传片，然后他们租用了这家总部位于英国的制作公司来进行动画制作，它上映于各大影院，并在接下来的几代人的
generations afterwards and it's And is that ongoing? So my brilliant impression of Liam Neeson in Taken, which we started this podcast with, I mean, are the CIA behind the scenes kind of encouraging the presentation of the CIA in a positive way in film and TV? And I'd say this is, what's his name? Jack, what's his name? Tom Clancy and all that kind of stuff.
教室里反复播放。而且这种做法还在继续吗？所以，正如我们这个播客开场所模仿的那样，我对《飓风营救》中连姆·尼森的精彩模仿，我的意思是，中情局是否在幕后某种程度上鼓励电影和电视中对中情局的正面塑造？我想说的是，这叫什么名字？杰克，他叫什么名字？汤姆·克兰西以及所有那些类型的作品。
Oh yeah, Jack Ryan. Jack Ryan, yes, yeah. Yeah, there is. I think after we touched on this briefly earlier, all of this stuff about Castro and MH chaos, et cetera, comes out in the 70s. And then actually the CIA hasn't been terribly attentive to its own sort of public relations up until that point.
哦，对，杰克·瑞恩。杰克·瑞恩，对，是的。对，确实有。我想在我们之前简短触及这个话题之后，所有关于卡斯特罗和MH-Chaos行动等等的事情都在70年代被曝光了。在那之前，其实中情局对自身的公共关系并不是特别上心。
But in the late 70s and 80s, it starts to become so and eventually actually creates a unit basically for liaising with Hollywood and various other cultural entities and plays a role in in various movie productions um zero dark 30 you know the um the the the movie about the hunt for bin laden that that has um there is quite a lot of consultation between uh the director and producer and and and the cia because there was a point wasn't there when when the first revelations came out about the cia sponsoring the congress for cultural freedom and then and then the revelations about the exploding cigars and stuff. The CIA was kind of toxic in American, certainly in American kind of intellectual circles. It was seen as evil assassins and shambling clowns and stuff.
但在70年代末和80年代，它开始重视起来，并最终成立了一个部门，专门负责与好莱坞以及各种其他文化实体进行联络，并在各种电影制作中发挥作用。《猎杀本·拉登》这部关于搜寻本·拉登的电影，导演和制片人与中情局之间进行了相当多的协商。因为曾经有过一段时间，对吧？当关于中情局资助文化自由大会的第一批内幕被揭露出来，接着又爆出关于爆炸雪茄之类的猛料时，中情局在美国——至少在美国知识分子圈子里——简直成了毒药般的存在。它被视为邪恶的刺客和笨拙的小丑之流。
But has that reputation changed? Certainly after 9-11, are people more benignly disposed towards the CIA now? Yeah, I think it did enjoy, I mean, it kind of popularity revived somewhat during the 1980s, you know, during the Reagan era. And so that, that was a sort of a Renaissance for the CIA, but then, then there was a further one. And the first Bush had been a director of the CIA.
但这种声誉改变了吗？尤其是在9·11之后，人们现在对中情局的看法是否变得更温和了？是的，我认为它确实享受过……我是说，在20世纪80年代（里根时期）它的受欢迎程度某种程度上有所复兴。所以，那可以说是中情局的一个文艺复兴时期，但随后，又迎来了另一个。而且老布什曾担任过中情局局长。
Yes, he had indeed. That's correct. Yeah. So, and right. And I guess it reaches a sort of nadir in the early noughties, you know, with 9-11 and the WNBT debacle and failure to catch bin laden and so on so then after bin laden is after the cia catches up with him it it sort of enjoys a revival uh then well so he in in the in the i mean kind of say over the past decade that the sense i have which i'm sure must be not entirely true because i'm only getting it from newspapers but the the action is
是的，他确实当过。没错。所以，没错。而且我想它在2000年代初触底，你知道，经历了9·11、大规模杀伤性情报的惨败以及未能抓获本·拉登等等。所以在本·拉登之后——在中央情报局追捕到他之后——它随后又迎来了某种复兴。那么，在过去的十年里，我的直觉是——这肯定不完全真实，因为我只是从报纸上了解到的——行动已经
going on online that it's it's kind of cyber cyber terrorism cyber wars whatever and the sense that certainly russian uh intelligence is now very very focused on the cyber and to be honest the chinese i've got no idea even what the name of the chinese spy agency is and i wonder in comparison to these much much more kind of shadowy figures is the cia kind of a bit prehistoric in comparison it's an interesting notion i mean i think it is trying very much to sort of adopt to this kind of new world of cyber threats uh etc and i don't think so i mean i think it's probably still something of a leader in that sort of realm of technological intelligence, as well. I mean, some people, you know, the 2016 Russian election interference, you know, a lot of some commentators have seen that as sort of
转移到了网络上，变成了网络安全、网络战之类的东西。而且感觉上，俄罗斯的情报机构现在非常非常专注于网络领域，说实话，中国的……我甚至不知道中国间谍机构叫什么名字。我在想，与这些更加隐秘的对手相比，中央情报局在这方面是不是有点太原始了？这是一个有趣的观点。我的意思是，我认为它确实在竭尽全力去适应这种网络威胁等新世界。我不这么认为，我是说，它可能在这个技术情报的领域里仍然算得上某种领头羊。我的意思是，有些人，你知道，2016年俄罗斯干预美国大选，你知道，许多评论员认为那是
blowback from earlier CIA operations, that the Russians were sort of imitating what the Americans would be doing to the Iranians. Oh, yes, of course, because the CIA with Mossad were kind of deprogramming Iranian nuclear actors and things, weren't they? Stuxnet, that's right. Yes, yes, exactly. Yeah, yeah, the unleashing viruses on them. So basically, I mean, is what's happening at the moment, that in the background, in cyberspace,
早期中情局行动的反噬，俄罗斯人是在模仿美国对伊朗所做的事情。哦，是的，当然，因为中情局与摩萨德曾联手试图破坏伊朗核计划等活动，对吧？“震网”病毒，没错。是的，是的，完全正确。是的，对，向他们释放病毒。所以基本上，我是说，目前正在发生的事情是，在幕后，在网络空间里，
where most of us have no idea what's going on? Yeah, okay, so we don't know. No one knows. Yeah, that's okay. So Hugh, I'll tell you one thing I'm very disappointed about. We have not mentioned, I was really hoping we'd mention, an alumnus of my old school. So I'm always...
我们大多数人都不知道发生了什么？好吧，好吧，所以我们不知道。没人知道。好吧，那没关系。休，我有一件事感到非常失望。我们没有提到——我本来真的很希望我们能提到——我母校的一位杰出校友。所以我总是……
I think I know where you're going with this proud old malvernian i'm always pleased to get my old school into podcast and i've completely failed so far in this entire series but now we can talk about a man called with a splendid name of james jesus angleton jesus thank god i thought yes so i'm desperate to get christianity so he should actually be james this is the height of pedantry, James Jesus Angleton, because his mother was Mexican. Oh, no. I've always thought of him as...
我想我知道你要说什么了，作为一个骄傲的老莫尔夫尼安（Malvernian），我总是很高兴能在播客里提到我的老母校，但在整个系列的节目中，我至今彻底失败了。不过现在我们可以谈论一个人了，他有着一个十分显赫的名字——詹姆斯·谢苏斯·安格尔顿（James Jesus Angleton）。谢苏斯（Jesus），谢天谢地，我以为……所以极力想要扯上基督教……所以他其实应该叫詹姆斯……这是吹毛求疵，詹姆斯·谢苏斯·安格尔顿，因为他母亲是墨西哥人。哦，不。我一直以为他……
He's a very interesting soul. But you can't call yourself James Jesus. You've either got to be James Jesus or James Jesus, right? You've got to be consistent. Anyway, listen, James Jesus Angleton. Okay. He went to my old school, and he was the head of counterintelligence at the CIA, I think from 1954 to 1974.
他是一个非常有趣的灵魂。但你不能叫自己詹姆斯·谢苏斯（James Jesus）。你要么叫詹姆斯·耶稣（James Jesus），要么叫詹姆斯·谢苏斯，对吧？你得保持一致。不管怎样，听着，詹姆斯·谢苏斯·安格尔顿。好吧。他去了我的母校，并且担任了中情局的反间谍主管，我想大概是从1954年到1974年。
What was he doing at your old school? Well, he was having a first-class education. What else? What do you mean? Why didn't he go to an American school? I think he popped up in Perifature or wherever. Hugh, you'll know the answer to this, do you? Yes Why didn't he go to an American school? I think he popped up in Periferture or wherever. Hugh, you'll know the answer to this, do you? Yes, I think I do.
他在你的母校干什么？嗯，他在接受一流的教育。还能干什么？你什么意思？他为什么不去美国上学？我想他是在……呃，外地或者别的什么地方冒出来的。休，你知道这个答案对吧？是的，我想我知道。
No, his father is a sort of international businessman. International businessman. Yes, there you go. That sounds like a euphemism. No, I don't think his father is a spy. Well, I say that actually. No, actually,'t think his father is a spy. Well, I say that actually. No, actually, no, he does play a role in the OSF. His father had a mountaintop lair in Switzerland
不，他父亲是个国际商人。国际商人。是的，你看。听起来像个委婉的说法。不，我不认为他父亲是个间谍。好吧，我其实这么说……不，事实上，我不认为他父亲是个间谍。好吧，我这么说……不，其实，他在OSS（战略情报局）里确实扮演过角色。他父亲在瑞士有一处山顶巢穴，
and a submarine that could swallow ships. Cigar? Right, anyway, let's get back to him because he was a brilliant man because he was completely paranoid. And he accused he believed that um the cio was full of communists he believed that he was a paranoid right-wing zealot he believed that harold wilson was a communist he went to your school he did exactly yes exactly i know some people it was that or become a a very popular mid-market newspaper colonist. I mean, it was one or the other.
还有一艘能吞下船只的潜艇。来根雪茄？好吧，不管怎样，我们还是说回他吧，因为他是个天才，同时也完全是个偏执狂。他指控……他相信中情局到处都是共产党人，他相信自己是个偏执的右翼狂热分子，他相信哈罗德·威尔逊是共产党人。他去了你的母校。他确实去了，是的，完全没错。我知道有些人，要么走这条路，要么就去当一个广受欢迎的中端市场报纸专栏作家。总之，要么是这样，要么是那样。
He kept telling MI5 that Harold Wilson was a communist. Yes. He also told the Canadians that their Prime Minister, Lester Pearson, was a communist. He told the Australians that their Prime Minister... The Mounties as well. The man running the Mounties counterintelligence, he was too. The Mounties were run by the KGB. So he believed everybody was penetrated by the KGB,
他不断告诉军情五处，哈罗德·威尔逊是共产党人。是的。他还告诉加拿大人，他们的总理莱斯特·皮尔逊是共产党人。他告诉澳大利亚人，他们的总理……还有加拿大骑警。负责加拿大骑警反间谍工作的人，也是。加拿大骑警已经被克格勃渗透了。所以他坚信每个人都被克格勃渗透了，
including the most anodyne and bland people imaginable. And yet they kept him on for 20 years. He's kind of going around saying, you know, you'd say basically... I mean, he does actually, he prevents communist penetration. I mean, all this actually works, this paranoia. You know, the CIA, while he's running its counterintelligence, is not penetrated by Soviet moles, where, you know, at the same time,
甚至包括那些想象中最为温和无害的人。然而他们还是留用了他20年。他到处跟人说，你知道，你基本上会说……我的意思是，他实际上确实阻止了共产党的渗透。我是说，所有这些其实都起作用了，这种偏执。你知道，中情局在由他负责反间谍工作期间，并没有被苏联间谍渗透，而与此同时，
I don't really need to spell it out, do I? The MI6 is thoroughly penetrated by Phil Beattal. And then after he's retired, you retired, he's kind of forced out because of this paranoid mole hunt he runs. Aldrich Ames, who's the most damaging Soviet mole in CIA history, happens along fairly soon after he leaves the picture. But yeah, no, he is undoubtedly paranoid. It's partly, I think think because when Philby defects, you know, this comes as
我其实不用把话挑明吧？军情六处被菲尔比彻底渗透了。然后在他退休之后——你退休了，他是因为自己搞的那场偏执的揪间谍运动而被逼走的——奥尔德里奇·埃姆斯（Aldrich Ames），中情局历史上最具破坏力的苏联间谍，就在他离开后不久出现了。但是，好吧，不，他毫无疑问是个偏执狂。我想部分原因是因为当菲尔比叛逃时，这对他来说是个
because he's one of Philby's biggest American buddies. They have a lot of boozy lunches together when Philby is running the Azor in Washington. So I think this comes as sort of a really big personal blow to Angleton who very much, you know, he
沉重的打击，因为他是菲尔比在美国最好的铁哥们之一。当菲尔比在华盛顿担任军情六处驻美代表时，他们经常在一起吃吃喝喝。所以我想这对安格尔顿来说是一个非常巨大的私人打击，他非常……
absorbed those gentlemanly values, you know, he absorbed those gentlemanly values, you know, patriotism, service, et cetera, while attending Melbourne College. Yeah, well, yeah, her Raffia was called Dominic. I mean, obviously, the idea that the CIA is sponsoring this podcast is a ludicrous one. Ludicrous. Ludicrous one. Unimaginable.
他吸收了那些绅士般的价值观，你知道，他在就读莫尔文学院期间，吸收了诸如爱国主义、奉献精神等绅士般的价值观。是的，好吧，他的拉菲（Raffia）酒名叫多米尼克。我的意思是，很显然，中情局资助这个播客的想法是极其荒谬的。荒谬。极其荒谬。不可想象。
I think if they were going to sponsor a podcast. Oh, my cigar just exploded. You might not have picked up on it, but I'm putting a positive spin on everything they did, you see. I'm getting it in there. So, Hugh, what was the worst thing they did? I mean, can I make a suggestion, and then you can tell me why I'm wrong.
我想如果他们要资助一个播客的话……哦，我的雪茄刚刚爆炸了。你可能没察觉到，但我正在为他们所做的一切进行正面的美化，你看。我把这层意思塞进去了。所以，休，他们做过最糟糕的事是什么？我的意思是，我能不能提个建议，然后你来告诉我为什么我错了？
Isn't it sometimes said that Indonesia is their worst, because they encouraged the purge of communists in the mid-60s. Thousands dying. A million people, some people say. Yeah, a million.
有人不是经常说印度尼西亚是他们干过最糟糕的事吗？因为他们在60年代中期煽动了对共产党人的清洗。成千上万人死亡。有人甚至说有一百万人。对，一百万。
And the CIA, I read online, I mean, admittedly it was only online, so it may be utterly untrue, that a CIA report had sort of set, its own report into it said, you know, this was as bad as Nazi mass murders or something. Let's hush it up. Hugh, is that all exaggerated or is that if there's some no no i i i i i don't think it is um amid all the laughter right it does you know a lot of these operations do you know lead to to very very bad things um iran guatemala you know the country uh after jacobo arbenz, democratically elected president, is overthrown.
而且我在网上看中情局的报道，当然，承认那只是网上看到的，所以可能完全是假的，一份中情局自己的内部报告曾指出，你知道，这跟纳粹的大规模屠杀差不多。咱们把这事压下去吧。休，这全是被夸大了，还是说确实有某种……不，不，我不认为这是夸大。在一片笑声中，你知道，其中许多行动确实导致了非常非常糟糕的后果——伊朗、危地马拉，你知道，在民主选举产生的总统哈科沃·阿本斯被推翻之后，这个国家……
And I think, you know, the finger really does point at the CIA and Washington with that one. You know, the country descends into a bloodbath. Not even the colonel who the CIA helped install this is sort of excused. He's assassinated a few years later. The operation against Patrice the Mumba, the Congolese president, that's absolutely ghastly as well. It's not actually the CIA. Because they send an executioner over, don't they?
而且我认为，矛头确实直指华盛顿和中情局。你知道，这个国家陷入了血海。甚至连中情局帮助扶植上台的那个上校也没能逃脱。他几年后被暗杀了。针对刚果总统帕特里、卢蒙巴的行动，那也绝对是惨绝人寰。其实不是中情局动的手。因为他们派了一个行刑队过去，对吧？
I mean, someone who's kind of practiced in poisoning. Yes, they send some of these poisons. The doctor or something, some sinister figure from a Conrad novel. Yes, Sidney Gottlieb, this sort of slightly Doctor Strange-loving character. Something like that, yeah. Yeah, he cooks up these poisons and dispatches them to the CIA station in the Congo to get rid of the mamba. The CIA doesn't sort of get to him first. These rivals of his and Belgian mercenaries do.
我是说，一个精通下毒的人。是的，他们派了一些这种毒药。医生还是什么人，来自康拉德小说里的某种阴险人物。是的，西德尼·戈特利布（Sidney Gottlieb），这个稍微有点像《奇爱博士》的角色。差不多就是这样。是的，他调制了这些毒药并将其派送到中情局驻刚果的分站，以除掉卢蒙巴。不过中情局并没有抢先得手。他的那些政敌和比利时雇佣兵先下手了。
But, you know, his murder is just horrible. And the CIA undoubtedly sort of contributes to this sort of atmosphere of murder and mayhem that surrounds him when he's eventually killed. Well, Hugh, I mean, obviously we're not sponsored by the CIA. mayhem that surrounds him when he's just when he's eventually uh okay well he he i i i mean obviously we're not sponsored by the cia that would be that would be an absolutely shameful allegation but i think that um before we go just one last question from danny k what was the cia's greatest achievement what was the cia's greatest achievement uh okay well i we've done the bad what's what's what's good? We've probably focused more on COVID action. It's kind of some successful operations like Iran
但是，你知道，他的谋杀案简直惨绝人寰。而且毫无疑问，中情局助长了最终导致他遇害的那种充满谋杀和混乱的氛围。好吧，休，我的意思是，很显然我们没有接受中情局的赞助……伴随着他最终遇害的混乱氛围……好吧，他……我的意思是，很显然我们没有接受中情局的赞助，那将是一个绝对耻辱的指控，但我认为，在结束之前，丹尼·K有一个最后的问题：中情局最伟大的成就是什么？中情局最伟大的成就究竟是什么？好吧，我们已经聊过了糟糕的一面，那么什么是好的呢？我们可能更多地关注了反恐行动。一些成功的行动，比如伊朗，
ultimately have bad unintended consequences. So if you sort of look at the kind of the ledger for COVID action, I don't think it's favorable to the CIA. But it's actually its intelligence record, I think, is actually kind of better than it's sometimes been given credit for. I mean, there are these there are some really egregious failures, you know, like 9-11, like the failures predicted, the collapse of the Soviet Union. I mean, big, big, big ones but the cia is very important in the yeah i mean it has some successes as well like the cuban missile crisis you know it does very well
最终却产生了糟糕的意料之外的后果。所以，如果你回顾反恐行动的账本，我认为对中情局并不太有利。但实际上，它的情报记录，我认为其实比有时人们给予的评价要好一些。我的意思是，确实存在一些非常严重的失败，比如9·11，比如未能预测到苏联的解体。我是说，重大、重大、重大的失误。但在……中情局在一些方面也非常重要，我的意思是，它也有一些成功，比如古巴导弹危机，它在那里的表现确实非常出色。
there actually a lot of the intelligence it provides during the vietnam war is is very sensible as well it it has a takes a pretty dim view of u.s prospects in in that war from early on so i suppose also a lot of i mean like a lot of these things, actually their successes, we probably don't know about because, you know, that's the point, isn't it? Well,
实际上，它在越南战争期间提供的大多数情报也非常理智。它很早就对美国在那场战争中的前景持相当暗淡的看法。所以我想，就像许多这类事情一样，其实它们的成功之处，我们可能并不知道，因为，你知道，这就是重点所在，不是吗？好吧，
you know, I, now Tom, that's actually a favorite sort of CIA publicity line. It is, it is, it is, you know,
你知道，汤姆，这其实是中情局最喜欢的一种宣传口径。确实如此，确实如此，你知道，
we actually have so many successes, but we can't tell you about them. Well, there it is. I smuggled it in. I hope my controller in Langley will give me a free cigar for that. Hugh, thanks so much. It's been a brilliant whistle-stop tour through – what's the fascinating subject?
我们其实有那么多的成功，但我们不能告诉你。好吧，就是这样。我把它塞进去了。希望我在兰利（Langley）的上司能为此奖励我一根免费雪茄。休，非常感谢。这是一次精彩绝伦的旋风之旅——探讨这个迷人的主题是什么？
Thank you. It's a weird and wonderful subject, isn't it? Yeah, thank you, Hugh. Thank you. For those of you listening, be careful with your next cigar. Don't pick up a seashell. And if you find your beard, if you're a hipster and you find your beard mysteriously sparser tomorrow,
谢谢。这是一个诡异而美妙的主题，对吧？是的，谢谢你，休。谢谢。各位听众，下次抽雪茄时要小心。不要去捡贝壳。如果你发现自己的胡子——如果你是个潮人——发现明天的胡子莫名其妙地变得稀疏了，
wait till you listen to next week's The Rest Is History and find out what happens then. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那就等到收听下周的《历史的剩余》，看看接下来会发生什么。再见。再见。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。